local law enforcement teaming up today  to remind people of the importance of  road safety especially with bikes and  emergency vehicles out there  organizers tell us they hope to educate  drivers and encourage  everybody to be more aware while on the  road this  after the death of tow truck driver ryan  billett last month he was hit and killed  while helping a driver on the 215  and of course back in december five  bicyclists were killed on u.s 95 near  searchlight  it's absolutely imperative that we focus  on the loss of life  this is not natural roadways and  cyclists and cars  the byproduct is not fatalities it is  you know we should be able to get home  safely every single day  he also says we are one of the few  states where vulnerable users like  people on  motorcycles people on bikes people  crossing the street  actually make up a majority of people  who are dying out on the roads  but together he says we can work toward  the ultimate goal of having  zero fatalities